[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is your places
call places for the top of the show
spring awakening was so hard to describe
1891 germany rock music there's children
in it the gay scene abortion the sex the
suicide there was never anything like
this that's ever happened on stage the
controversial nature meant that we never
thought about broadway but it touched a
nerve we became rock stars
[Applause]
getting back together after 15 years is
gonna be insane
for the years we worked on it we were
rejected everywhere and everyone thought
we were out of our minds
when we were in previews we were losing
money big time it was a disaster it
really didn't start well michael said to
the cast the future of this is in your
hands and that night something happened
in that theater
[Music]
[Applause]
if you were able to see spring awakening
at the atlantic theater you've got to
see something very special people were
jumping for joy and shouting it was
totally surreal it felt like we were the
beatles
we of course
loved our show and loved playing our
characters but the real fun we had was
off stage together
through the cast and through the
opportunity of getting to play this
character i had grown this
strength
and it changed my life
the things that we confront in this show
are not things you can learn in school
and there are things that help people
survive that's kind of what got us
through it every night knowing how
important it was to tell that story
this was not about this reunion this was
an opportunity to be with those kids and
see who they've become
i would not have survived the experience
it wasn't for all of you
i learned that dreams can come true
[Applause]
you